shortages of natural gas supplies have
sent prices soaring in europe pushing
many many energy companies to the edge
and challenging major industries who
rely on the fuel now the shortage is
also promising higher heating bills for
the coming winter
there are a few key factors behind the
energy crunch in europe the long winter
depleted supplies of gas on the
continent alternative energy sources are
meanwhile tight wind turbines at a near
standstill in the north sea as winds
there stopped blowing and asia is taking
up a large part of liquefied natural gas
supplies
all of this now as natural gas
deliveries from russia fall
russia blames infrastructural issues
such as a fire at a processing plant in
siberia but some believe the country is
throttling supply as part of a bigger
geopolitical game
beneath the town of raida and lower
saxony natural gas is stored deep
underground a subsidiary of gazprom
germania has filled the gas reservoir to
only two-thirds of its capacity it's
normally 90 percent full in the run-up
to winter
energy consultant andreas loscher is
concerned about the rise of gas prices
demanded by russia germany's largest gas
supplier
russia is a very strategic player in the
gas market which means that economic
interests are in the foreground
shortages naturally drive prices up and
are very profitable to russia
more than half of germany's natural gas
supplies come from gazprom germania a
company close to the kremlin the company
has declined to comment
gazprom built the nordstream tube
pipeline through the baltic sea at a
cost of 9 billion euros it's technically
ready for operation but still lacks the
regulatory green light critics of the
project now see a link between the
shortage of natural gas
and the sluggish approval process
i can only assume that this isn't a
coincidence because russia has plenty of
gas it could deliver the pipeline
capacities are there political pressure
is being exerted to ensure that
nordstrom 2 can go into operation as
quickly as possible a number of european
permits are still missing and i believe
that president putin is simply playing
politics with gas supplies to germany
and central europe
relief could come from liquid natural
gas which is available worldwide but the
liquefied gas tankers are currently on
their way to asia where natural gas is
scarce and prices are high the eu is
left empty-handed
heating and cooking will be expensive
this winter alternatives to natural gas
are in high demand
this gas price
this high gas price this gas crisis will
certainly also lead to a readjustment of
energy policy
i think we will consider how we can
become more independent of gas
especially in the area of heating which
affects households but also companies
we will look for alternatives especially
grain energy and the expansion of
renewables
the high price of natural gas could
backfire for russia's gazprom in the
long run prompting a boost for further
investment in the development and
rollout of green energy sources at least
that's the hope
all right ashitash pandey is our
correspondent in frankfurt ashtosh good
morning what can we really say about
russia's role in these shortages
good morning stephen uh russia is a
major factor there but it's it's wrong
to entirely blame it on geopolitics or
the politics around the north stream too
uh look russia itself uh witnessed a
very cold and long winters and it is
replenishing its stock now because its
gas stocks were actually uh they also
went down drastically during the long
winter months so
it's now boosting those supplies so
also russia is actually producing gas at
at its highest level say in a decade for
this time of the year so it does not
really have a lot of spare capacity to
boost output having said that the
international energy agency does feel
that there is still scope for russia to
boost output and supply uh to uh to
europe and that would actually show that
it is a reliable supplier
touch we looked at some of the factors
uh multiple factors beyond this behind
this crisis i should say
climate change is also playing a role
correct
oh absolutely and these are these
extreme weather events uh so
typically in summer months europe and
european companies they actually
replenish their stocks the gas stocks
which are
which get diminished during the winter
months but what happens during summers
this year there is like a heat wave in
southern europe so that means there is
more demand for air conditioning which
means more demand for power and in
return more demand for gas so that
couldn't happen then if you look
beyond the continent there was a drought
in brazil that's the worst drought in a
decade and that meant that a country
that typically realized normally relies
on hydropower had to turn to lng to meet
the short supply uh and that meant the
fewer cargos for europe so there are
these direct consequences of climate
change that's already being felt
ashitash uh briefly how are power
companies dealing with this crisis right
now
well they're struggling to say the least
but uh
uh we can expect higher prices you
mentioned there and that will they're
going to transfer those a higher price a
higher cost to the consumers some
countries have said that they are going
to cushion the impact on end consumers
uh and some have also turned
interestingly to coal uh but then coal
is also in short supply the code price
is also going through the roof uh there
was a shortage due to heavy rains in
indonesia and colombia which are major
court producers
and and also because there were
shutdowns at mines during the pandemic
so it's it's sort of a perfect storm for
the energy markets uh uh if i could call
that
all right pandey in frankfurt thank you
very much